hi everybody there we go
I'm Eric I'm gonna be your presenter for
the next half an hour oh boy so this is
where I work you want to email me now
you can do it one two three okay as my
background I did a bunch of stuff I got
to work for the White House that's why I
have a t-shirt that says White House on
it because I bought it at the White
House whoa
all right I don't really care about my
background too much especially for an
audience like this so I'm just gonna
jump right into the things so the
general gist of this talk or the sort of
theme here is to teach you how to take
the skills that you've acquired as data
scientists and software engineers and
then apply that to the social justice
context and I'm going to be doing that
through a high-level algorithm of
basically what I did these are the
condensed steps that I took to move my
career from a place where I was only
looking to make money to a place where I
was looking to help people now I have a
slight advantage over all of you I
started thinking about this stuff when I
was 12 so when I was 12 I was on
vacation with my parents in India and I
saw slavery and I saw a guy that looks a
lot like this and the image of a person
that was enslaved really broke me and I
was like all right I'm gonna help people
for the rest of my life and so I've just
kind of been working towards that ever
since technology and me being a math
nerd and all that other stuff kind of
helped and so the key point here is that
it has to start with a feeling you have
to want it you have to want it more than
anything else because the pay and a lot
of these social justice jobs are really
low like embarrassingly low they've been
getting better and I've been pushing
people in New York that paid software
engineers more money and that technology
does actually matter and in some cases
this is actually yielded real results
for instance I used to work for the
Manhattan DA's office and they recently
put up a posting for a software engineer
for the entire department and they're
actually gonna pay them like below
market rate but not like so much low
they can't afford to live or eat which
is basically the choice that I made when
I worked there so I moved back in with
my parents which was super fun and then
I got to save lives every day all right
so once you have decided that you are
going to do something semi masochistic
and I am going to argue that it's
becoming less and less masochistic every
single year and that more and more
people are waking up to the fact in the
social justice space that you need
software engineers if you really want to
make an impact that scales and data
scientists it's easier and easier to
find your people for me this was the
anti-trafficking folks that I worked
with and you know I went from basically
being an academic that no one really
listened to and constantly pushing my
professor though my advisors to be like
let me do anti-trafficking things to
being able to work with people on the
ground that were like yeah let's try
things let's get out there let's do it
and you know let's see what we can see
let's let's find let's find the results
and it fundamentally changed the
direction of my career and was sorry I'm
just gonna get rid of this little iTunes
jump in window that's what I get for
trying to charge my phone well I give a
talk please go away
alright and so yeah being able to find
the right set of folks with the domain
expertise really was able was what was
able to bring me to that next space so
the first thing I'm going to show you is
a tool that I made
alright so key points wanted to just to
summarize super fast make sure you want
to do it and then once you do it find
people to work with and this is going to
be a counterexample because I did not
find people to work with when I built
this so back in 2000 and I want to say
oh gosh 11 or something
I made this tool so what this does and I
actually should have had this slide up I
had it before and then I decided to take
it down so anyway so what this does is
I'd wrote an analysis for the Huffington
Post I showed this pattern in case you
can't see that so it was 2013 excuse me
on two days after Thanksgiving so last
week basically but in 2013 there was a
huge spike in the number of people that
were on Craigslist looking for
prostitution now the reason why I bring
this up is because some set of
prostitution is human trafficking
specifically sex trafficking where this
is not a talk about anti-trafficking
work this is a talk about how you can
change-the-world those so I'm sort of
jumping through a lot of the details I
have many other talks that are on the
internet about human trafficking as well
as there are now many other
professionals that are doing this as
well so I encourage you to go check
those out okay so anyway so I found this
pattern I thought that would be it the
way I found it is I so now we're gonna
dump into the data science side of this
I wrote X classifier hooray like the
first thing you do when you get out of
grad school I think this is
approximately the right thing to do if
you're gonna do text classification
tf-idf is not always the right call I'm
gonna like claim that that was like a
feature engineering thing that I did
because I was dealing with like
advertisements so it's paragraphs of
texts and then people sort of say it's
soliciting the world either for sex or
the other way right like they're either
saying I want to buy this or I have this
and want to give it to you and so I was
able to parse out pretty pretty easily
which were you know prostitution which
one weren't and then from there it was
like sort of anyone's guess but you can
sort of say from the magnitude annals
shift on like thanks get the day after
thinks the weekend after Thanksgiving
that there is something substantive here
okay so let's dive into the details of
how this works I set up a nice little
pipeline if you're not familiar with
scikit-learn pipelining basically what
this does is sort of like imagine that
there are variables here so like there'd
be like a variable over here there'd be
a variable over here and there'd be a
variable over here and you're sort of
passing the data implicitly down the
chain so the variable comes in here it's
processed by this and then there's like
a function call that happens where
tf-idf so count vectorize happens first
then tf-idf happens and then the SGD
classifier which among other things does
support vector classification so SVC
within the within the scikit-learn stack
when I ended up trading this it turned
out that SVC was the most important
thing most important classifier which I
found kind of interesting and I do a
bunch of things I'm regular rising which
is something you should also do I'm
using some parameter tuning I'm setting
a random state to ensure consistency all
these things notice that I have a call
here from my limit Iser which you know
I'm sort of wrapping in a standard way
if you're not familiar climatization
it's super cool it allows you to sort of
say that things that are plurals like so
like
dey's becomes day semantically which is
what you care about when you're trying
to classify text you don't care about
the difference between day or days
you're trying to get at some level of
high-level semantic miss to be able to
put things into a bin and soul Emmet
ization is the right thing to do I claim
and others claims so I trust that and
I'm using the were Matt we're we're net
lemma tiser because I think it's pretty
good okay so this is not the cleanest
version of this there are other people
in the Python community that will yell
at me for using a class and then having
a call which basically means why the
heck wasn't this just a function and I'm
gonna claim there is like some good
reason for doing this because I've
setting up this limit Iser so there's
this object that's instantiated inside
of it and it's a little weird to have a
function where you have a limit Iser
like another class instantiated and
you're gonna reinstate that class every
time so this allows me to store state so
this is one of the few places when I
think it's actually defensible to do the
thing that I did okay so hopefully if
you want to argue about it we can argue
about it later I'm certainly you know
game for that argument but I I think
there's some defense here then the last
thing I do is I just call this grid
search thing so hopefully this is like a
familiar thing for most of us in the
psyche at line space all right so you
would think that this tool was like
great you know I found this pattern cops
are gonna go arrest a bunch of people
whatever there's culture change everyone
realizes that trafficking is happening
in New York City and then they decide to
do something about it maybe a little bit
of that happened but like not to the
same level that I was expecting so
essentially what I did is I built
something crappy that was mostly wrong
and then I took it on the road I gave a
bunch of conference talks so this is
before I worked the DA's office I want
to claim that and that's important but
this talk this analysis allowed me to
get my job at the DA's office
I gave this talk at PI Gotham like I
don't know I guess it must have been in
2014 and there was someone the audience
from the DA's often is like we're
starting up a human trafficking unit
would you be interested in like working
on that I was absolutely quit my job and
then you know moved moved on to the the
DA's office and that was made possible
because I showed effort and interest not
because I build something that worked
when I actually started getting on the
ground and working with people in the
DA's office I found oh this is like
basic
uselessness and now they know the
problem is real they need like very
specific help on specific things and
we'll get to some of the specifics that
I was able to build for them and
hopefully gives you some ideas of what a
good solution looks like technically
alright so our next thing I built I'm
moderately sorry that Miriam mm okay so
I'm moderately proud of of this thing
not because it's well-designed I cannot
take credit for this there was someone
who helped me with a hackathon built the
design because it actually shows
something that is a value to people
whoops what is going on oh no
okay sorry I clicked on the wrong tab
that one is still being I actively work
on this tool so every once in a while
things break but that is not the this is
that link I wanted to show you so all of
these dots are places that I claim
trafficking has happened in New York
City this is data from that's very old
it's very stale it's likely these actual
addresses no longer have sex trafficking
happening at them but this gives you a
much better more substantive view and
just to zoom in a little bit these are
places that like we are kind of close to
you right now right so okay maybe I
can't zoom in come on let's go Internet
yeah so these are places that we're kind
of close to you right now this is not
happening far away in some distant
corner of New York City this is
happening in major locations so you
would think this then would raise the
call and people would get more
interested too bad they already care so
all we're doing is saying get angry
about a thing that you're already angry
about if you already in the space and if
you're not already in this space then it
tells you so all of us are very
frustrated by this but the people that
work on this day out and day out are
like yeah we know great you made us a
prettier map they don't actually care so
I would claim that being able to do that
sort of thing which is largely what the
anti-trafficking space has been about
for many years I mean making the call to
arms is important I can't underscore
that enough but the way that you really
help people is honestly by doing things
that are a little less sexy a lot of the
time but can still be you know super
useful alright so before I jump into the
big this is the thing that actually
worked
we're going to go through the technical
details of investigate
and how I sort of built that tool and
we're gonna start by looking at vgg
sixteen so vgg sixteen is a
convolutional neural network so I'm not
doing anything crazy right now with this
confident all I'm doing is importing the
model from chaos because chaos is super
awesome and comes wrapped with a whole
bunch of architectures if you're not
familiar with chaos
congratulations you just found the
secret weapon to all of your neural
network problems you'll never have to
try very hard again the tensorflow under
like API changes like with some level of
regularity that kept sorry why is this
not letting me okay come on I can't oh
I'm already at the bottom I must have
passed by it yeah okay this file is much
shorter than I realized anyway so vgg
sixteen is one of these neural
architectures that neural network
architectures that comes out of the box
and it's really kind of amazing and so
what this is what this is currently
being used for is taking a bunch of
pictures and this is generally what it's
used for it's taken a bunch of pictures
and then doing image detection
especially when you use image net now
grant it you can use this architecture
for a whole bunch of other things like
image classification facial recognition
it's all about the training data that
you pass it right so here we're passing
in the image net weights and that is
what allows this to be used as an an
object detection neural network so to
speak so like the data is kind of
informing the use case alright so how is
this actually happening we just read in
the model right so the image here let me
see where we're getting that from so
image is also a pre-processing step that
comes from Chios completely free and
like you know just kind of available for
us so we're just loading that in and
then the reason we set the target size
is because I cut all the images down to
224 by 224 so that's just like something
that comes that that I'm setting I
should not have hard-coded that but like
whatever
it made the object detection like
reasonably easy to do at that size for
some reason I don't fully understand how
image sizing affects object detection I
think it has
do with pixels but like there's probably
something more nuanced here in any
events so I set the pixel size to that
by that and then you know there's all
these nice utilities that you get so
image to array turns it into an umpire
array so then you can do your standard
neural network stuff that you might want
to do at any given point expand dims
flattens things I'm choosing the zeroth
access because it's flattening across
the rows not the columns and then I have
this preprocessor that I wrote I think I
did not okay this is also a vgg 16 thing
magic so you know we're getting a lot
for free because Karros is kind of
amazing and sort of expects you to be
doing object detection with it so if I
haven't convinced you that key RS is
like the greatest thing ever then I
don't know what else will if you're not
doing cutting edge neural network
research if you're doing cutting net
research and you like want to do the
capsule net or whatever that hinton just
invented like a couple weeks ago or a
month ago at this point then this is not
the right thing for you if you're doing
literally anything else so if you're
doing image classification if you're
doing object detection if you're doing
any regression problem literally at all
if you're doing time series
classification you should use chaos you
should not use tensor flow that is my
claim we can fight about it later for
sure all right so the last thing that I
think is interesting in this specific
piece of code is what happens here so
once we have done the predictions and
we've gotten our predictions and this is
pre trained so we only have to run it on
the predictions we don't have to do the
training piece of this because imagenet
if you're not familiar imagenet is I
believe three million images and a
thousand categories that were pre
trained by some researcher who was super
amazing and hand labelled all three
million images into each bucket so
that's kind of nuts they did a lot of
the work for us it is expensive and hard
to do object detection there are other
algorithms that have made the
performance better but as far as I know
I think this is the only object
detection at scale sort of thing that I
know of there may be other ones happy to
hear about those if they exist so I like
this one a lot and then what you can do
once you have your predictions right so
right now these are just like numbers in
an
ray you do decode predictions and then
it gives you the semantic categories
back ray which is what we care about
so you'll notice there's some other
things going on here I didn't just write
a object detection thing I also have
elasticsearch here so now I've got like
image search locally or on the Internet
not on this map not on this website
because the search doesn't work here for
a lot of reasons one be super racy
pictures and I really don't want expose
anyone to that who goes to my website -
I've given this talk to teenage girls so
I definitely don't want them to see it
and then like three I don't want the
traffickers to know that I'm looking at
them specifically I feel like it's a
visceral reaction if they find my stuff
if they like see like you know one of
their victims in one of these pictures
so the data is stale but like I'm just
there are closed source versions of this
that are behind passwords that do you
have the search obviously alright so
going back into the code so for those of
you not familiar with the elasticsearch
API in Python it's super easy to use you
just have to pull in the elastic search
object and then you can do a little bit
of magic I'll get into this a little bit
more later but more or less let me just
drop down wait where is it uh okay so
I'm saving it to the database man
remember man okay I think this actually
might be further down in the text oh I'm
not actually okay so some of this is
commented out whatever oh no it's over
here yes it's over here sorry yeah this
goes a little hacky the open-source
version is not as up-to-date as the
closed source version that's why I'm
sort of like oh what did I do here this
is something I've written it just took
it's been a while since I've worked on
the open source version so anyway so
once you have the images which I'm
saving to a database for obvious reasons
I can then dump things into elastic
searches by doing ES index giving it the
index name the doctype and then the data
here the data is not the image it's the
labels and then the file name is also
going into here so it's the label and
then the file name the file name is
referenced by
the web version of this and so you get
the image and you get the labels
associated with the image so this is
like a really nice operationalized
little tool right like you can use this
if you want to see what pictures of your
cat's from your vacations are like doing
things but it also can be used for this
real word world use case now this has
some marginal benefit for people in the
anti-trafficking space but it's just
like a fun thing so I'm spending some
time on it because this is a data
science conference and we should talk
about data science see things all right
so that's investigator it helps people
to some degree I personally am a fan of
it but like there's still some things
that need to be worked out before it can
actually be operationalized or useful
for anyone so there's a lot of work for
building a system like this all right so
the last thing I'm going to show you and
this one actually kind of frustrates me
because this is the thing that most of
the people that I work with really like
and want to use everyday so I'm actually
going to run this code locally you know
I guess whatever God you believe in help
me okay so most people laugh when they
see this so I'm just preparing you for
how ridiculous it is so this is the
thing this is the tool that I made that
helps most of the people that I work
with at any given time looks super dumb
right that's because it is super dumb I
spent like three hours of this so I'll
just give a quick demo of what this does
if I can find some data so let me I
downloaded the talk somewhere I think
it's an AI conf no ifs excuse me okay so
here is a PDF version of my slides I'm
gonna upload this great it's uploaded
and now I'm just gonna go back to the
the title slide and I'm gonna copy paste
and then we're gonna search for that oh
cool we found it so this is like really
bad user experience right this is like
the most ugly terrible thing that I've
ever made in my life and I'm embarrassed
that this is the thing that people like
what to use but it's fine it's fine
everything is fine
I get really angry about this anyway so
what this does is it allows alright so I
have to give you some context now for
for the the DA's office I just want to
do okay so I've 15 minutes left
approximately all right there's enough
time for me to go into the full
background so here's why this is so much
more useful than anything else I built
and before I get into it I wanna I'm
gonna hammer at the beginning of this
explanation and I'm gonna hammer at the
end that the reason why I'm showing you
this thing is because it's not always
the super sophisticated machine learning
algorithm that's crazy that's going to
save the world sometimes it's the really
dumb thing that you built in three hours
that for some reason social justice
people find really easy you got to
understand where people are and meet
them where they are most of these folks
do not have search okay so that's the
first thing I want to claim and that's
the reason why this is useful does
everyone remember maybe in the 1980s if
you were alive this thing called oh now
I've to remember the name and I'm like
blanking on it of course it wasn't the
internet it was like you could you could
what no no no it's it's not that it's
mainframes so yeah so most social
justice yeah yeah you're like oh my god
that most yeah yeah so most social
justice like organizations around the
world use mainframes to this day they do
not have file search because they're on
a mainframe and they do not have really
anything because they're on a mainframe
now I don't mean that they're using like
COBOL and Fortran I mean that they're
using Windows but like really really old
Windows now we're in Microsoft so I want
to be clear Microsoft of today is
awesome actually the fact that they've
pushed into open source and that they
built their own Linux these are all
super amazing things and the company of
today is way better than the company of
ten years ago but so is everyone so like
you know we shouldn't fault them too
much but yeah so they're running these
really old like Microsoft hacked
together mainframes that the IT people
understand and so everything just lives
in this giant mainframe
there's like 10 million a hundred
million files and these are all Case
Files and personally identifiable pieces
of information and they're all one
running on Windows XP so the world is a
magical place sometimes so what this
tool does is it gives them a ficient and
effective file search now we're gonna
look at the source code it's laughably
small so we can do it in 13 minutes but
the point here and I'm gonna drag you
through the mud hitting you over the
head with a hammer or whatever metaphor
I need so that you understand it is the
easy thing that saves lives it is not
the super sophisticated machine learning
thing that's why I gave you the
scikit-learn and the vgg 16 those are
sexy applications that we all care about
but like these folks don't always anyway
now that I've beaten you over the head
with a thing I can walk you through the
source code and we can all be sad
together you're with me now
we're off a journey not allowed to back
out okay so there's a few things that
happen the first thing is I parse the
file so I'm using elasticsearch again
this code is a little bit more
maintained so I know my way around it a
little bit better it's also a little
cleaner because I only returned for
three hours so this is a docx Python
super awesome it comes with a duck a
document library you can parse documents
super cool that you can parse doc X's so
what this does is it looks for any doc
X's when they get uploaded it means like
the thing that happens in the view don't
worry about that now
excuse me but this assumes that I'm
passing in a docx file and then what it
does is it just adds it to the index
remember when we looked at elasticsearch
we're just adding it to the index so we
added to the index we have the data so
that's the text in this case and then
the title of the document and then we go
back up a directory now yeah I'm using a
file system on the internet which is bad
practice and I know I should be using s3
and also there's stuff but I built it in
three hours so coming some slack
alright so the simplest one to implement
was parse text this took me five minutes
and then I started thinking well maybe I
could do this one and that's sort of
what led to that and then here comes the
backflip all right so remember I always
said before that you know machine
learning isn't really useful for these
people I want to make a caveat machine
learning can be so useful to these
people when they don't need
understand that it's being used they
don't understand the nuances of machine
learning
they understand cool you made my life
ten times easier and so you can always
do those sorts of things now granted
again this is like not the right way to
do this I could have done a lot more
training for this I'm using the
out-of-the-box solution from octopus
which is now called aqua rope I for some
reason so occupy is an OCR solution it's
super great
I really recommend checking it out one
of the reasons why it's so amazing is
because it comes with a pre trained
recurrent neural network but you can
train your own so you can always make
your OCR domain-specific PDF style
specific we have solved the parsing of
PDFs problem in the machine learning
space I think and this is an example of
how that does that now this is like a
hacky thing I'm using some command line
stuff which I know is terrible I
apologize to the gods of clean code but
this you know got the job done in three
hours because my life is too busy at
some point in the future I will probably
return to this and like a train a better
recurrent neural network on this and be
like you know actually learn the
internal interfaces so that I don't have
to deal with these command-line
arguments basically what this is doing
is it parses the file it puts the
pictures into this weird temp folder
with question marks for some reason it
runs the recurrent neural network
against it because it's text it goes
character by character across and
recognizes each one think of this like
Amnesty except operationalized so you
could probably get a lot more mileage
out of capsule med or a res net or some
other thing I don't remember if res
Nestor used for character things I feel
like it was trained on damnest at some
point but that might not be true so
maybe that one is wrong I know capsule
net was trained on M nests because I
just read that paper a couple weeks ago
so yeah so I could say with certainty
that capsule net would get improved
performance over this vanilla recurrent
neural network and you would just have
to run this against this anyway not
important so then you have this this
last step which basically turns it into
an HTML documents
HTML documents are things that the
Internet's as well as Python knows how
to parse super well we just take the
HTML document we do a from string we
ignore some ASCII things and then we get
the text and then we're able to just
turn it into here so this is dealing
with picture PDFs these are PDFs that
were scanned in which is true of most
legal offices that can't afford an army
of paralegals which is most social
justices offices
so you're thinking ACLU you're thinking
most anti-trafficking NGOs you're
thinking I don't know whatever social
justice startup you want to think of
maybe Doctors Without Borders as well
not to call them out I don't know if
they all do this I'm assuming the ACLU
does and I know some anti trafficking
NGOs do all right so and then if we are
lucky enough if we are in the universe
where this is a PDF that has been OCR
already or is just text readable because
it was translated directly from the word
document that someone wrote and then
they emailed them to someone else in
that luckiest of Lucky Worlds we can
just do PDF the text and then to pass in
the - layout command I have not figured
out a better way to do this this will
probably live this way forever I
apologize there are tools like in Python
called parse and all the bunch of other
stuff but I haven't found them to be
super compelling PDF the text is super
compelling to me you pass in the file
name and then it takes it from a PDF and
turns it directly into a txt file and
then I call the txt parser so that gives
us pretty much what we need and that's
why this thing is a beast it'll work on
any file type that most of these people
have now why is this super useful okay
most people don't last in NGOs for more
than about two years the pay is terrible
the hours are awful and the work is
heartbreaking so you go into this NGO
maybe work on a legal case for two years
then you leave to go back to the big
fancy law firm and you came from all
your domain knowledge goes out the
window when you leave and so they're
left in a lurch so if they want to find
the files that you worked on and it's
not in their head before this tool then
way of recovering those those specific
things so they really need this to be
able to say okay we found this guy with
phone number who's related to that like
other case that we worked on like four
years ago does anyone remember any of
the like specific pieces of information
this is really a lawyer's talk they
don't take notes like in a detailed way
because anything you write down if you
remember it like you have to turn over I
can remember what the name of the legal
thing is but you'll have to turn it over
but discovery yeah so like they keep
their they've lawyers are trained to not
take notes whether they mean to or not
I'm not saying there's something like
adversarial although there is something
ever serial here they don't take notes
by they take notes when they have to but
they don't take notes a lot of the time
sorry that was really confusing and in
my head so they don't take notes a lot
of the time and so these PDFs were
really the only way that they'll be able
to recover a piece of information so
this is both helpful and can be hurtful
to a case but on the whole it's helpful
because then they can make the internal
connections between this trafficker and
this trafficker over here do the social
network analysis and then if this
trafficker there's a legitimate case
against them and this trafficker we
don't know but maybe there is you can
join the two of these people together
based on stealing information that is
personally identifiable like a phone
number which is basically like a unique
identifier or their social security
number or in some cases to a lesser
extent their name or their address then
you can prosecute both of these people
now I won't get into why this is like
super useful tool to large degree
there's other talks that I've given that
you can check out the long story short
is that trafficking victims basically
don't want to deal with the legal
proceedings they want to get out of
being trafficked obviously and then they
want to go away that makes sense legal
cases are really hard there's a lot
there's a lot more nuance there I'm not
doing it justice please look at other
talks online to understand why more
detail oh yeah so that's why this is the
most amazing thing I've ever built and
if you want to work in social justice
space I hope you do I hope that this is
incentivized you that you can at least
try to or at least you know maybe do
data kind help out on the weekends all
of these things are options you don't
have to make it your day job now
shameless plug at the end I get to work
on social justice stuff every day
because I work at this place
we do social justice stuff
that's like part of my job anyway so
that's like shameless plug thing done
here are a whole bunch of organizations
that are doing things I always reference
this one first why is my internet not
work but this worked like yesterday ok
maybe not is it this one come on
internet oh maybe it's down or whatever
I guess their internet thing is down
that one is like they write you a check
for 15 grand if you want to do it I
guess it's just like they stopped paying
for it so maybe that's not happening
anymore anyway whoops should've checked
in any event there are a lot of
organizations that do this I worked with
Bayes impact a little bit when I was at
the White House they're super great they
do data science for social justice
they're nonprofit but they help people
beta NYC is here in New York City the
largest social justice meetup I think in
the world definitely in New York and for
sure in America they're super amazing no
Hidalgo is like their leader and he does
a lot of amazing work and they do data
science for social justice they were the
first in the space and they helped me a
lot early in getting to the right people
when I was starting out so you know they
are an amazing group and if you want to
do this work they are super great a
bunch of these other things Code for
America is another one that I'm going to
call out specifically they do a lot of
great work a lot of people that ended up
at the White House when I was there did
Code for America first so there's a
whole career path for getting involved
if you really want to make this your
career and then there's a whole bunch of
other organizations that I've been
tangentially involved in but all of
these are amazing and you should
definitely check out every single one of
them ok so I think we're at time
right when do I go until 12:00 10:00
oh I've got like 10 minutes cool so I'll
take the last 10 minutes for questions
hey anyway look one over there Thanks
yeah yeah so so just to repeat the
question what's the legality on this to
öhlins particular right so this is not
enough to make an arrest this is enough
to start an investigation that means
that they can start they can go to a
judge and say hey this person is shady
give me a warrant great then they can go
not a warrant for arrest warrant for a
search warrant
yeah the like start investigations and
stuff that's all that means before that
you can't even look at a person like the
we do general human trafficker people
involved in anti-trafficking work do
general discovery things on a regular
basis and so they're constantly looking
for you know traffickers to prosecute
because witnesses usually can't come
forward because they're enslaved right
so like it's kind of hard so when
they're doing this discovery for people
they get enough evidence so they can get
to the next level this definitely helps
with that not enough to make a huge
impact this tools may be being used by 3
to 3 organizations so like not that much
but like yeah so but that but this this
allows them to open the door before that
they couldn't even open the door of the
investigation there's been a lot of
people that have done the discovery work
actually like I think there's some
people who do num focus things that also
help with this and like other things and
generally the Python community
definitely has been involved which has
been wonderful to see yes next okay one
two
yeah I know I do I've friends at thorn
yeah so I'm actually just about to start
a doctorate probably I don't know
whatever I'm like pre doctorate land
I'm helping a professor with the project
right now and it's probably going to
turn into a PhD and his last PhD
candidate went to Thorne and I'm taking
over her research so I know for sure
that I'm doing things that are similar
to thorn not this stuff this stuff is
not related so that's so super
fascinating I'll say the high level it
involves crypto currencies and payment
methods and then I'm gonna wave my hands
and like you can go read the paper
because that's like a whole big thing
but yeah there was a thorn hackathon
just to call it out there was a horn
that thorn hackathon like a couple of
weeks ago in New York City it was super
great I went Ashton Kutcher was there
which was really weird cuz he like funds
the organization and I was like oh
you're ten feet okay cool whatever weird
and that was interesting but yeah we got
to work on a bunch of stuff there were a
lot of great projects and a lot of
people did a lot of great stuff there's
definitely people in the space and a lot
of folks a lot of familiar faces that
I've seen from other social justice
things okay you're next oh you're good
okay cool answer your question alright
one two so you and then him oh sorry can
you say it louder oh yeah sorry I didn't
like go into that at all it's really
gross pictures of men and women being
naked and in various contexts so there's
this website called back page I will not
go into detail about them or what they
do but they have a dating section and
most of those are just prostitution ads
yes that all comes from websites like
back page there's a ton of these things
in the internet so I don't give this
context because this is not anti
trafficking talk this is how you can do
social justice work in the real world
but the Internet has fundamentally
changed and I'll just give the spiel
quickly the Internet has fundamentally
changed the way in which the value
proposition around sex trafficking has
evolved the Internet has made it cheap
and easy to connect buyers and sellers
of all stripes and sort of flavors
unfortunately this means it's easier to
buy and sell people and so with the rise
of Technology and the internet we have
created sort of a crisis we've made you
know sort of the sex trade or the sorry
the human the human slavery trade 2.0 on
top of everything else Silk Road you
know provided a lot of ground for this
web sites where you can buy and sell
people all of these things creating a
second-hand market
honestly cryptocurrency has been a big
part of this because it's not tracked or
regulated by any nation you know part of
the reason why we have laws and
consequences is because we can track
these things and we can control for
certain things we can audit stuff we
can't do that with this new technology
and I'm not saying technology or
innovation is bad necessarily but there
are consequences often unintended that
we need to take care of and this is an
example of how technology has led to
sort of the bad so my claim is that we
can do better and we should and that's
part of the reason why I do this work
okay you and then you write you got a
question oh sorry I thought it's like
you raise your hand okay so you you're
next yeah absolutely we have an
internship program at my job so I didn't
want to give a plug about where I work
because that feels really wrong but I'll
explain what we do so we work with law
enforcement agencies and we help them
try to better understand how to
effectively do community policing so our
value proposition is that we want people
who are getting policed by the cops to
have a say in how they are policed and
for the cops to better understand when
they're upset about a thing so that the
cops can do better this directly relates
to the anti-trafficking work I do
because the algorithms are similar and
then I can sort of take what I do here
and then give it to the anti-trafficking
people to some degree we have an
open-source footprint all this stuff we
have an internship program so I'm we're
an example on I'll just say that there
are other examples Bayes impact is
another example I don't know if they
have internships I'm not as familiar
with their hiring process the only
reason why I set us first but I know for
sure that they definitely do stuff I
don't know what the ACLU does this sort
of work with technologists but I imagine
you could reach out to them and they
would be super responsive every NGO
I've cold email has gotten back to me
within three days there is plenty of
space for all of you to play if everyone
in this room decided they were gonna
like nah quit their jobs but sort of you
know to five hours a week for one of
these social justice things I bet you we
would move the dial on every single
social issue out there that matters
anyone else okay going once going twice
alright thanks everyone a really
appreciate your time
[Applause]